[Inaudible].
Well, thank you very much to all of you. There was so much to think about that.
I want to begin by actually picking up that last point that Tony made.
If I may with you for harder, you're in a hurry, the motion says it all.
We're talking about climate collapse. Why worry about overturning the system?
Why not work with what you've got?
Because we've been trying for 30 years to have legally binding targets and caps
and they haven't happened. So it's not like we've not,
not thought about any of these things. You know,
we've got to the point of rebellion because we've understood that the system
cannot create the solutions that are necessary for its own transformation in a
more sort of elegant way. Audrey Lord,
who is a feminist poet thinker, strategist, um, you know,
so said it very nicely.
Actually she said for the master's tools will never dismantle the master's
house. They may allow us to temporarily beat him as his own game,
but they will never enable us to buy genuine change.
That's my insight from the last 30 years, we've been banging our heads,
trying to do exactly these things and the very industries,
the very countries that are dependent then on these industries cause entire
countries are then dependent on some of the largest industries
are not making the change. I did want to add one more, very large subsidy,
which is the military. So fossil fuel, you know,
takes place now largely in hugely authoritarian regimes.
The destruction of nature is backed by a fist of force.
Nature, defenders are being killed and those regimes are held together.
That is an additional cost in the system.
And we don't talk about it and it requires radical change. It has had a,
you were a regulator in various different guises.
Why are we still having this conversation? Now,
if it was possible to drive through the kind of change that that Tony was
talking about?
Well, because we didn't win the argument, but we've got to win the argument.
But I think the challenge for George and for Harner is they say we failed to win
these arguments in the past lobbying.
And the power of money has prevented having tight enough,
a rules and regulations.
So we're going to abolish capitalism,
but you're going to have to win the argument for bullishing capitalism.
Why is it going to be easier to win the argument for abolishing capitalism than
to win the argument for regulating capitalism?
The point is we've got to win the argument and once we've won the argument and
got the legally binding targets that Tony talks about,
we will then find that having a market place,
which helps you work out the details of it will be better than having public
ownership of the means of production and distribution and exchange.
Because I do think it is incumbent on for Hannah and George to say what the
alternative is. It's very easy to say, we hate capitalism.
It's not going to work. The alternative is public ownership of the means.
Of production of distribution exchange.
And we know that when that was applied in Eastern Europe and Russia,
the environmental impacts of that were far,
far worse than the impacts of capitalism.
You began to talk about a possible alternative.
Do you want to expand on this private sufficiency public luxury?
Yeah, so, so the principle of it is it's not state control. I'm not a communist.
You know, there's this assumption that if you're against capitalism,
you have to be a communism as if a communist is,
if there's only two options in this fascinating and complex world,
but the massively neglected sphere of the economy and the one
which delivers both equity and environmental protection is the one that no one
ever talks about, which is the commons.
We discuss this as if there's only two kinds of economy,
there's the market and there's the state, but actually the commons,
which is used to be huge is huge.
In some people's lives is a bit where we control what goes on around us.
Neither. The state does it. Neither the market does it.
We can control public services. We can control land. Um, we,
the local communities are able then to exercise far more power
in decision-making than we can under either of those other systems,
either capitalism or communism, both take power away from us.
I'm all for taking back control, but not in the way that Dominic Cummings here.
Tony Juniper, come on. What's,
what's wrong with that kind of regulation where it's not regulation,
it's real people running their own lives and making their own decisions.
I've spent much of my career trying to correct a phenomenon called the tragedy
of the commons, uh, whereby leaving people to have their own, uh,
agenda in terms of how they manage natural resources,
leads to them being trashed, whether that's the logging of forests,
the exploitation of fish stocks, or in this country,
the trashing of the uplands by sheep grazers who have Cominos rights.
So it's not necessarily a solution to this particular set of challenges.
It can go badly wrong.
If it's not regulated that it's not under some kind of legal control based upon
some kind of ecological outcome that all of society subscribes to.
I would say that we're far better to have the imposition by governments of
legally binding caps on the missions, along the recovery of nature,
and to use a variety of tools, to be able to achieve those ends,
including some of those tools, which are at the center of the capitalist system.
I'm not against people having common rights,
but I just don't see that that would be a solution that would replace
capitalism.
This is a completely discredited notion. I mean,
it's been totally destroyed and ripped down. And what Garrett Hardin, who,
who proposed that idea did was to confuse an open access regime with a
genuine commons where there is control. There is regulation by the people,
the fundamental thing that both Tony and that air are fighting against all the
time. The question why this hasn't happened already.
Despite decades and decades of efforts is that capitalism.
Not only is an economic system. It becomes a political system as well.
It empowers those politically.
It empowers people who gain the Pruett's of capitalism and they
prevent this change from taking place.
That's why we're in the fixed in Finland.
Well,
they presented it in Finland as a capitalist economy is a capitalistic economy
with a social democratic government now committed to zero carbon by 2035.
Why isn't that an attractive capitalist fund?
Yeah, so we can, you know, there are many types of capitalism.
It's not one thing or another, there are slightly better versions out there.
And I think the issue is that even the slightly better versions cannot really
get to grips with the scale and rapidity with which we need to
change. They're all locked in now. They can't do it even like nice, nice Norway.
Let's look at nice Norway, mice, Norway just had a legal ruling,
which said, which was, you know,
they were taken to court by the domestic NGOs for more drilling in the Arctic,
more drilling in the Arctic, nice Norway here saying, you know,
we're the better drillers cause we have higher standards than those baddie
ones. You know, out in Venice, they're still drilling.
They're still drilling like the one of the richest countries in the world.
Another example that I would love you to look up the Amazonian,
Amazon sacred headwaters,
an area larger than the size of the UK with a little bit of Wales added
a huge area, huge area, three different countries own it. Peru,
Ecuador, Brazil.
This area is pristine in his home to indigenous people,
many millions of them who have lived there in harmony,
looked after their forest.
And now it's being opened up to drilling and oil.
You tell me how you fix our system now,
because that says that entire area is about to go, uh, during,
unless we're talking about, there is no way to stop capitalism from doing that
[inaudible] to rip it out.
Well, I mean, for Hannah, you said it,
there are many different forms of capitalism and capitalism can have new
deals. Capitalism can have new ways of doing it,
which can involve significant roles for the state alongside the private sector.
You use this term new deal. We all use the term new deal.
The new deal was afraid of Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
who I think was the greatest American president of the last century.
Franklin Delano Roosevelt did not say he was anticapitalist indeed.
What he introduced by his policies was the absolute glory days of capitalism,
where it delivered what capitalism can deliver more effectively than ever
before. And we can win these arguments and we have to because the alternative,
if you simply come forward in the political process and say,
we're going to reject capitalism, frankly,
I think it will makes it less likely that we will get the tough measures
required to the change we needed.
Indeed.
Now we're going to, we're going to, there's so much to talk about.
Everyone's bursting to talk. Uh,
we're going to open the debate up to all of you before we do that.
I just want to reveal the results of the pre vote.
That's how you voted when you came in.
So 38% of you are for the motion to stop climate collapse.
We missed an capitalism.
28% are against and 34% are undecided.
So you're the ones that, uh,
the panel has to persuade that we all have to watch. So we'll go to the floor.
This is your chance to take part.
Hello.
My question really relates to some of the examples that have been given
of the countries, whether it's Finland or Norway. I mean,
frankly in the great scheme of things, rather small in terms of population.
If we look at the very large populous economies
of Asia,
of India and of Africa and ask the questions of
how you end capitalism or end
consumerism in those societies,
some are democratic,
some are not democratic that just doesn't seem to be addressed.
We also have the other major economy of the United States,
which seems to have gone off on a sort of private and rather peculiar mission of
its own.
Okay, let's have the second question number two over there.
So I'm not entirely sure that I agree with either side of this question,
but most of this is, is directed towards the pro side of the question. I mean,
it's, as it was, was sort of brought out, I mean,
is that a reasonable estimate of what
fossil fuels are subsidized for is 5.6 trillion? I mean, it's, I've seen that.
And it was also sort of brought out that the cost of renewable energy
has dropped enormously. And in fact, I mean, it's,
I think that the most reasonable conclusion is that renewable energy now
is less expensive than fossil energy. So given those two things,
I mean, just that,
is this really a political question in the sense of just convincing people
to withdraw these subsidies,
that and remove the restraints on allowing
renewable energy to come forward?
Or is it an economic question where you need to overturn the
entire system?
So I would think that that really comes down to something that's very
simple. Just you, you get out of the way. I mean,
just to end the problem solves itself. Okay. Thank you. And number three.
So I had the question to both sides, which was, um,
the pro side said that, uh, if we include,
continue with economic growth in order to let people out of poverty,
we're going to go straight into, uh, that's gonna huge heavy sheet and actually,
um, our resources and our environmental boundaries.
How do we practically bring beyond poverty while we'll say,
and while not having economic growth and then to the against side,
how do we bring back that poverty with economic growth,
with growth while not growing our current emissions in the global North?
Thank you very much. So, uh,
the comparisons with Finland and Norway not really relevant when you think about
the populations of places like Asia and Africa, who, you know,
how do you end capitalism when those people want to consume what the standards
of living that perhaps we've enjoyed the cost of renewables has gone down.
Is this a political question about convincing people to withdraw subsidies or an
economic question about overturning the system and how do you bring down poverty
without growth or equally? How do you save the cloud? Save the environment,
uh, at the expense of, uh,
and yet actually allow people to move out of poverty. George,
do you want to go first?
Sure. I mean,
it's interesting picking up the contrast between the U S and Finland,
as you say, the U S far more powerful. I mean, overall, globally,
capitalism's becoming more extreme, not less extreme.
We've moved away from the social democratic era of capitalism,
the Keynesian version of capitalism towards this extreme neoliberal market
fundamentalist version of capitalism.
And the reason for that is that capitalism generates its own momentum.
People gain power under the system,
and they play the system with the use of that power.
Are we seeing any of the things we want to see happening? No, we're not,
not nothing nowhere near the scale that we need to see them on
because to go to the second question,
because of the sunk costs already invested by large capitalist
enterprises, be it Exxon or BP or whoever it might be,
they have got their investments, which they are trying to protect.
And they use political means like funding Donald Trump or
Scott Morrison or Jaya both Sinero in order to protect those
investments. And they gain control over the system as a whole.
So for years and years, all four of us on this panel, you know,
and I applaud and salute at Aaron, Tony for all their efforts.
We've been trying to fight this system from within, are we winning? No,
we are failing spectacularly because you cannot fight it from within
because it generates its own power. This is why we need to be pressing.
And with this, this is an effort of global persuasion to say,
we have to fight this from, without, by demanding and creating a new system.
[Inaudible].
Pick up the point about small and large population countries. In fact,
uh, the greatest part of my focus this year is on the de-carbonization of the
Chinese economy. I'll be spending about.
Six weeks in total in China,
probably not in the next couple of weeks has been a little,
a little little delay in the launch of our next thing.
And what we are trying to do there is to persuade China that it
could be a zero carbon economy by 2050 Zetia ping
has a phrase, China 2050, a fully developed rich economy.
And we have recently produced a report called China 2050,
a fully developed rich zero carbon economy.
Now is China a capitalist or socialist country company economy it's called
locally a economy of socialism with Chinese characteristics.
Um, some people think it would be better to be called a capitalist economy with
Chinese characteristics. It's a funny mix,
but it has a very dynamic private sector. The solar PV panels,
the, the, uh, the batteries,
the EVs are all being developed by amazingly dynamic, uh,
Chinese entrepreneurs overlapping with a state sector.
Many of which of those state-owned companies almost act as if they were private
companies in the terms of the way they look after the managers of those.
So it's, it's a complicated thing to understand,
but it is certainly a form of market economy with many of the aspects of
capitalism to it. It's still building coal fire. And I have to say,
if I turned up, well, let me come back to that. If I turned up there and said,
okay, guys, what you have to do is to reject capitalism,
we'd get nowhere, right? What happens in China is fundamental.
Their emissions are now 10 gigatons of CO2, 12 gigatons,
including the other greenhouse gases.
Ours are 450 and falling even on a per capita basis.
They are going above UK and European levels.
And to win the argument in China, there is only one way to do it,
which is to convince them that it is technologically possible for them to be
a proud, rich developed society.
In which Chinese people enjoy the opportunities,
the economic opportunities that we enjoy,
that it's technologically possible to do that and be a zero carbon economy.
That's how you have to win it. And in order to deliver it,
you also have to use powerful market economy techniques involving
entrepreneurs competing with one another to drive down the cost of batteries,
to drive down the cost of electrolysis equipment,
to drive down the cost of solar PV.
So I think when you look at that large population country,
whereas I say that is where most of my focus is this year.
I would say the idea that we have to approach this issue by suggesting the
rejection of capitalism is just completely the wrong way to go.
I'm going to pause you there. Cause for Honda wants to come in. Yeah.
On the question of subsidies. So in 2009,
the biggest richest countries in the world that G seven came together and agreed
to phase out fossil fuel subsidies 2009. Okay.
So that's why I'm convinced that coming together and trying to get these
agreements,
which then are negated is impossible in this system without
something else happening. And that's something else happening is first of all,
I think my opponents need to accept the failures of the system.
And that's why I'm here to convince you,
but also to convince them to have a little bit of a wake up
moment, a little bit of a tournament, a little bit of a yes,
we failed because we did not recognize the magnitude of the
political weight and the magnitude of the problems can not be fixed
with techno managerial solutions.
The second point I want to make is about populations.
So many of the countries that you suggested,
many of the continents that you suggested have extremely low per capita
emissions is not the size of the populations that matters.
It's their consumption,
whether they're doing it within their own countries or offshoring it
actually elsewhere.
So China's emissions are mainly coming from us and consumption by us.
Is coming. You can't say something, which is just not true on a 10% off.
Let me finish. Let me finish. Well, that's 10% is still allowable,
but it's not, it's not most, it's not.
But it's the richest people in the,
in this country that are responsible for the bulk of the UK is emissions.
So the bottom 75% remember the pyramid of
extraction. They don't fly, they don't have cars,
they don't have second homes. They don't have the kind of luxury lifestyles.
So I think we need to not keep looking at whether it's population that's the
driver. And I think Tony's also very fixated on population as the driver of
destruction is actually this extractive system,
which accumulates for the benefit of.
There's a whole queue of people up there with questions. Tony,
I'm going to give you a last chance just to go back to the questions on some of
the points.
So I'm, I'm,
I'm in total agreement with this idea that we need to change the system,
but there are two really important questions that you must answer.
When you say that number one is change the system to what,
and then the second bit is how do you change the system?
And so we need a clear pathway between here and where we're going to go next.
And if we're going to go somewhere where we're going to want to take 7.7 billion
people with us, we have to have an offer that is both realistic and attractive,
and which has got some means of garnering political and democratic support for
it. And so we have to be very clear. I have thought about this a fair bit.
And I think that probably our best chance in the 10 years that we've got left is
to adapt the existing system into something that can start to look like it's
ecologically sustainable.
If we just push it into the margins,
what do we finish up with? We finish up with a lot of chaos.
We finish up probably was unemployment.
We finish up possibly people not having energy or food,
literally because all of those things are presently delivered by capitalist
organizations and without a pathway between here and what we want to change too.
I think we're going to be wasting our time far better to advocate the change in
the existing system. Let's change the hard caps in law.
Let's change the subsidy regime. Let's put a carbon tax in place.
Let's give capitalism of purpose and let's change the measure of GDP to
something which is more about what society needs.
Let's take some more questions.
[Inaudible].
I'm going to go, just to say the final vote is taking place.
So hopefully you've all put your cards in and if you're still undecided,
you put the whole card in. If you're not, they're all there,
I'm going to go up to the balcony and take three from up there.
So go for it and be brief. Cause we're not a lot of time.
Tony's five point plan seems precise and pragmatic.
Please can Farhana and George respond in a meaningful,
engaged way to those points and
clarify to what extent that plan could
achieve your stated, uh, future goal. Thank you.
Uh, I actually agree that Tony's plan sounds great.
And I think both Tony and Adair have admitted that for capitalism to win this
argument, capitalism needs to change.
The big challenge is who's going to change it. Who's going to force that change.
I mean, who here trusts the politicians of his country to run a bath,
nevermind change policy, the capitalists themselves,
these companies that the Belmonts of capitalism have known the science,
not for 10 years,
don't known for 50 years and they've done nothing about it that she counteracted
what they need to do.
So who is going to actually realistically make that change?
That's what you need to convince us that we're going to come with you on this.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
Um, so I'm a mum of three and, um,
I think I'm going to ask a question that my kids would probably want to know the
answer to, um, which is, so if 70,
if there's 100 companies that are responsible for 70% of CO2 emissions,
since the 1980s, um, the people at the top of these companies,
why don't they care? Are they psychopaths?
And the government has said that they support. W yeah. And secondly, um,
I want to ask for a gut feeling here from you guys. Um,
maybe a little bit of hope for me please. Um, have we got this?
Can we apply the brakes in time? Um, or, or my kids who are eight, six,
and four,
going to die prematurely in some kind of climate related war over resources.
Thank you.
[Inaudible].
I'm going to start at this end of the table just for change Adair Turner.
Let me answer that final question. Um,
Graham ski said you must be a pessimistic of the,
but optimistic.
Of the will.
You must carefully work out what your chances of success are with a
bias to pessimism so that you are realistic,
but then you must try and change those chances.
I am 100% convinced that if there were
a benign deity again above us,
and if she sent angels in the night to steal all our fossil fuels by
2050, that we would by then build a zero carbon economy.
And that we would hardly notice the cost of getting there on economic standards
of living. I think there's about a 30% chance that we will do that.
And my frayed,
my blunt belief is that the 70% chance we're probably going to fail.
So my aim in life is to turn 30 to 31 to 32 to 33 in
Europe, particularly in India and in China where I work.
But in order to shift it from 31 to 32 to 33,
I think turning up and saying that the thing to do is to reject capitalism
rather than reform. It is likely to reduce the probabilities that will,
I will increase that from 31 to 32 to 33, rather than increase it.
But that I'm afraid is my honest assessment of the
odds as we face them.
And what about the question about do those companies simply not care?
I think it.
I think, uh, they're all fossil fuel companies,
which now take the science very seriously. Um,
and I think there are others and I'm not going to name which they are, uh,
which really don't at all. I think, uh, there isn't a,
a unified approach within the fossil fuel companies, the world.
I think there's quite a spectrum of different points of view. No, no look,
they are fossil fuel companies,
but some of them want to get out of fossil fuels and some don't, some are,
some of them are denying the science and others are not denying.
Okay.
So let's take the ones who aren't denying the science like shell and BP shell
won't even tell me what its investments are in renewables.
They do not feature in its annual report because they are so tiny.
Instead it is trying to invest as much in fossil fuels this year,
as it invested last year and the year before and the year before,
it's trying to maintain those investments because that's where the value of its
capital is.
We asked why don't these people care that people might care.
The system does not care.
They have a fiduciary duty towards the investors in that system to maximize the
value of their investment. That is the central premise of capitalism.
What are Aaron Tonio trying to do is to take a system, which has,
I hope I demonstrated at the beginning is innate sleep.
Unsustainable innately drives us towards disaster and says,
let's turn it round and make it sustainable. It is innately,
destined not to be, they are chasing unicorns and.
I hope you haven't voted for them.
Hold on a very brief, one more question. Absolutely.
You're absolutely right.
That many of these companies knew they've known for 40 years and their
strategy was to obfuscate, deny and delay.
Every month they delay is usually millions of pounds.
That's why I told you about what Saudi Aramco does. Its strategy,
literally second per second, delay of the inevitable.
And they have huge power. These industries to stop that they are on trial.
Lawyers are taking them. Citizens are taking them to court.
I hope as a lawyer,
those legal processes will deliver justice.
I hope that the opinions like this debate will show
to those CEOs and everyone who's in touch with them,
that they are failing humanity and their legacy will be one of
destruction. Okay. So that's what I'm saying, but I, I feel,
I want to say now eco side is what is happening.
It fits the facts.
I want to take one more question from the floor because as for Hannah rightly
pointed out to me, we only heard from one woman.
So I'm going to go to the woman in the yellow jumper there.
Wait for the microphones just behind you. Very briefly as you can, because,
sorry, I only said that because you wanted to women. Um, the question,
the question I have to stand, sorry. Um, the question I have, I, I think is,
you know, China has had a benevolent dictator for two and a half thousand years.
He's the man you have to persuade president.
She has a control of such a fast potential.
You know, when they wanted to reduce their population,
they introduced a one child policy. They did it overnight.
They can create change overnight more or less.
So president she is the man that you have to talk to.
I think there's an invitation to data.
Let me just get out my mobile phone.
Is it fair to put it all at the, uh, the foot of president Xi?
This is a very middle-class conversation in some ways,
isn't it about us just to bring it back here in the UK.
Is it fair for us to ask those countries over there to change their ways?
We're we're not prepared to change ours very briefly?
Well, the answer is in this country,
I raised issues about people's lifestyle, right?
About what I or other people have done in terms of their transport choices,
their diet choices. I mean, that's a legitimate here.
I don't raise those issues in China because at the moment they have a GDP per
capita at about a third of us.
So I don't think it's appropriate to raise those issues when they're still at
that level. I think you're broadly, right? That China is not a complete,
it's actually got more decentralized power structures. And you might think,
and it has some coal lobbies, which by the way,
aren't state owned coal lobbies preventing some of the
move towards renewable energy,
which is primarily driven by private entrepreneurs.
That happens to be the way round in China,
but we do have to try and influence the Chinese power structure.
The good news is there's lots of,
there's lots of bad news about the Chinese power structure,
but it is a technocratic scientific structure that believes in
experts. So when their scientific experts say climate change is for real,
the image glam glasses are going to melt.
This is going to do terrible things to our river flows. They take it seriously.
So one has to work with that and see whether one can get more aggressive targets
for decarbonisation than those that are in place already.
George or Ivana, who would like to answer.
That's such an easy question, I'll leave it to them.
I think, you know, we're always waiting for the right leader to come along.
And I feel that one of the mistakes of the past has too has been that
we didn't involve people. We really didn't involve people.
A lot of these technical plans, a lot of these solutions were never tested on,
you know, tested with people and were they willing to accept that? So yes,
leaders matter, I'm not saying that Chinese leadership doesn't matter,
but the leadership of people, the voice of people matters even more.
And that's why, for example,
extinction rebellion has been very vociferous in demanding citizens'
assemblies and selections.
And I would say in response to the question about what are your alternatives,
actually, you know, all of the executive boards,
all of the decision-making structures should now have mandatory
representation of every cohort and of population.
So there are pragmatic ways in which we can fix governance without going to
nationalization and ownership. This isn't about that.
You can put three,
three young people who sit on all of the decisions. Why not?
You can have an ombuds person who looks after the rights of
citizens. Those who are excluded from, from voting,
who are literally not being seen and heard in the current voting system.
So there's lots of ways in which practically we can reform capitalism.
But I think after that reform,
it doesn't look like capitalism and it won't result in all of the egregious
degradation that we've been talking about.
We're going to wrap up the questions there because as ever a time is short,
I think you've been taking part in the final vote.
There's some furious counting going on somewhere the motion,
just to remind reminder, to stop climate collapse, we missed end capitalism.
We're going to hear final summing up speeches from our panel.
Tony Juniper, if I can ask you to go fast.
Well, what I've heard this evening is not only a discussion about economics.
It's also been very much a discussion about politics and where power lies.
And if we are going to be able to change our in time to avoid climate
collapse and ecological catastrophe,
we are going to have to find ways of getting enough power behind the kinds of
alternatives that we think will work. The question was in the room this evening,
who will change it,
who was going to put in place the kinds of shifts that we need while I'm afraid.
Ladies and gentlemen, the good news is that it's all of us through being voters,
through being activists, through being conveyors of ideas,
the fantastic work that George and Farhana have done over the years to raise
awareness,
to put inspiring ideas into the public space and then to demand action.
This is essential,
but at the same time as having increased citizen participation,
we have to have an idea of where we're going and what we're going to do.
We have 10 years remaining.
That's what the intergovernmental panel on climate change tells us,
nevermind the catastrophe that's unfolding in the tropical rainforests and the
coral reefs from parallel pressures being exerted on those places.
If we're going to be able to make the most of this small window of opportunity
that remains, we have to work in the real world.
It's all very well condemning capitalism and saying it doesn't work.
We all agree with its downsides.
What we have to have as a workable alternative that will get the backing of
voters is great. That China's got a more or less benevolent dictator,
but I really shutter to think of the idea of advocating dictatorship as a
solution to this.
There's some very bad experiences globally throughout the world.
As a result of that particular style of sorting problems out,
we have to educate citizens. We have to inspire them.
We have to get them to back. The kinds of policies that we know can work.
And those policies are embedded in the existing system that needs to change
fundamentally, but changing. It is going to work better than chucking it out.
[Inaudible] over to you. So.
I think there's so much agreement that the solutions are there and that a lot of
it is about political will,
but I think the new system looks something like this.
I think land is massively taxed. Okay.
Land isn't taxed at the moment what you do on it is taxed.
So land comes back into some kind of commonly held
concept. And I think British law, English law, common law has many,
many brilliant ways in which we can do that.
Many of you live in flats where you have a lease and there's a
freehold. So we can construct many different ways in which we can,
all co-own things.
And it's not all straight state-owned or owned for private profit.
We can put a young people,
we can put lay people on all of the decision-making boards that there
are in all forms of government. I live in Camden,
we've already had a citizens assembly.
We've now experimenting with what we call a think and do.
Pop-up where the community comes and collaborates.
They co-design and collaborate. That's what we're testing.
So it's far from a dictatorship it's far from this rather nasty model that
you're putting forward, which is, I think, you know,
we're still trapped in the mentality that we're all gonna go. If we, if we,
if we denounce capitalism that, you know, we're, we're pro Stalin or something,
that's pretty much what people seem to think. And that's really not,
not the case.
And we have a positive vision and that vision already exists and it's called the
sustainable development goals. And it's been adopted by every single country.
And it consists of interrelated 17 goals,
which all of society,
every human being means that they're not left behind from prosperity.
And it means that there's no competition,
no fake competition between people and nature between people in one country
or another we're working collaboratively together. All of that's been agreed.
The green economy is by and large already,
or already here actually generates more jobs. And you're not seeing it.
You're not hearing about it because they don't have the lobbying power to
influence, uh,
and pay for the kind of sophisticated ads for billions that you see from the
fossil fuel industry, which is, you know,
faking it and doing greenwashing whilst doing business as usual.
So lots and lots of things to look forward to and nothing to lose
from stepping back from the edge.
[Inaudible].
I think George posed the fundamental question.
Is there something structural in the very definition of capitalism so
that it is bound to be environmentally destructive?
And I think Tony put the argument very effectively against,
because he set out a five point plan of believable things that you
could do,
which if you put them in place would have a capitalist
economy, which would be environmentally sound,
a capitalist economy in the only meaningful sense of a capitalist economy,
which is that most firms would be privately owned.
There are restaurants would be privately owned.
All hotel companies privately owned our car manufacturers are battery
manufacturers.
Our solar food manufacturers would be privately owned.
Now in order to get anything like Tony's program, we have to reform capitalism.
Absolutely fundamentally. And I absolutely agree with Farhana and George,
that one of the problems is that the very process of capitalism produces
concentrations of wealth that can have a political influence on policies,
which are perverse. So we have got to win the argument against that,
but I think we are far more likely to win the argument against that.
If we are arguing for a reformed regulated and controlled capitalism,
rather than suggesting that we should reject capitalism in favor of some other
model, which we're not really allowed to know what it is,
because I don't think you are clear what it, because you cut,
but not imposing.
That is a bit of an article of faith for us to accept that we'll just,
we'll find this thing, which we don't know what it is. And I would put it down.
If at the end of the day,
you're not saying that you want to nationalize restaurants and hotels and
battery companies and car companies and electrolysis companies.
Then you are accepting capitalism in any reasonable sense of the word
capitalism, George Mumbia.
Nope.
Despite being our opponents, these are good people
who I greatly admire, and it's a pleasure to debate with them.
But the question they have repeatedly failed to answer.
Is why haven't we won yet?
Everything I've been hearing them say,
I've been hearing them and people like them.
And people like us say for my entire working life,
35 years, we're all in the second blue review from this panel.
Tony's five point plan. Marvelous. Brilliant, fantastic.
I've seen it for 35 years. People putting this stuff forward,
why haven't we won yet?
And the reason we haven't won yet is we're up against a system which is innately
unreformable because of its intrinsic characteristics.
We would love to reform it. We would love to have everyone coming out,
all the capitalists coming out of their boardroom, singing kumbaya.
It is not going to happen. It is not how capitalism works.
Capitalism is a system for accumulation. It accumulates profit,
it accumulates power. It accumulates natural wealth at other people's expense.
And we are seeing the results of that. Now why,
despite all these marvelous things we've been hearing,
are we not pulling back from catastrophe, but accelerating towards it?
It's because this is not a system that can be reformed from within.
This is a system that must be overthrown and changed.
This is a system whose days I sincerely hope are numbered. Thank you.
[Inaudible].
We could go on for some time. This is fabulous. So I have, in my hand,
a piece of paper,
which is the final vote on the motion to stop climate collapse.
We missed an capitalism. Now, before the debate,
38% of you were in favor of the motion.
28% were against and 34% were undecided,
but now 35% of you are for the debate.
58% are against and 7% of you
still don't know what you're saying.
Really lovely.
Thank you very much to this fantastic panel,
George, Tony. Thank you all very much.